[Albano Berberi playing violin]
>>Albano: Music is
pretty much everything.
I've been with music pretty
much ever since I was born.
I started out with a keyboard.
I was playing the keyboard
ever since I was around 5.
They say by one year I was
able to play the demo pieces
of the keyboards perfectly.
>>And then I started the violin.
>>And there goes a door.
The screen output is minimal at best.
Most of the game is
played by sound alone.
Now I'm just running
through a passage.
Whew!
>>Basically I just encountered
this mad scientist that goes
around stealing my things.
>>Student: Come on, Albano.
>>Albano: If you have like sound
orientation skills, you can do it.
>>Teacher: Let's go to page 275
in our books real quick just
so we can review that and then
we'll have some people come
up to the board.
>>C minor seven diminish six.
>>Albano: Six of two.
>>Teacher: And the
last one is in E major
and that's seven diminish
six five of four major.
So Albano, what did
you get for this one?
>>Albano: B flat, D flat, and G?
>>Teacher: B flat from the key
signature, D flat and G. Good.
>>Richard : This sounds
a little strange
but in 2008 this is a
wonderful time to be blind.
Digital documents allow content
to be displayed in multiple ways
like hearing it, feeling
it with braille.
Students who couldn't
see a computer screen
or see a text book page can
now listen to the textbook
or feel the textbook
in a braille version.
Students that haven't been
able to use their hands
for writing papers can
now speak to computers
and have their speech recognized
and converted into print.
>>Answer, air pressure
prevents this from happening.
Source-
>>Richard: The beauty
of universal design is
when accessibility features
are built into the environment
or into an educational system these
features are usable by everybody.
>>Gerald: We're going to go
back and review the grid world
because the grid world is
a big piece of the AP Exam
which we have two weeks
to get ready for.
So today we're going
to make a dancing bug.
>>Albano: We call it
Dancing Bug Runner
when it should be Dance
Bug Runner maybe?
>>Teacher: Okay, yeah, you're right.
>>Terry: When he first came here
he couldn't speak any English.
He spoke Greek only.
In a year he learned
to speak English.
He learned to read and write braille,
devoured anything I could give him
that had to do with computers.
He just has blossomed with that and
it allowed him to be able to compete
and to just be a part of high school.
>>Albano: Wait, should it be
in the code or in the folder?
>>Gerald: One of the
things Albano has here
on his computer is a program called
Jaws which reads to him what's
on his screen and he's able to
do 90 percent of the work here
in computer science
using that Jaws program.
>>Gerald: And in fact I
think it actually helps him
in doing programming because it walks
through the program sequentially.
It reads each and every line to him.
>>Albano: ...
backslash, where did they put it?
Oh there we go.
>>Gerald Bilodeau: Doing computer
programming is by sequential logic
and so where other students
tend to get hop around and look
for quick solutions, Albano
works through it line by line.
The other students in class here
they get confused a bit by having
so many options on the screen whereas
if they got through the program step
by step sequentially as
Jaws reads it for Albano,
I think they could
benefit greatly from that.
It would force them to go
through the program line by line
which is one thing the
students don't want to do
and I'd love to have them do it.
>>Albano: Oh I set to "H".
>>Gerald: It's set to "H", yeah.
>>So what we're going to do first is
we're going to share the limericks.
>>Albano: The assignment was to write
a limerick but I was kind of inspired
so I wrote five verses
and then I went home
and wrote the keyboard line for it.
>>This is called "Albano's Tale".
It's a rather self-ridiculing
limerick.
I hope you like it because
it was fun writing it.
>>[Singing] "Oh there once
was a lad named Albano.
It was said he played the piano.
So he sat and [inaudible] and started
to clean it 'Let's spin
us a tune' said Albano.
So Albano [inaudible] and instead
started trying to sway, as he tripped
and fell flat and his spare
[inaudible] went blatt,
was a sad and horrible thing."
>>Teacher: I want you to negotiate
by yourself that little curve
that goes around the rotary.
There you go.
>>Now just put the map
in your head, Albano.
We crossed Huntington
and we walked on Mass.
Ave. Now we've crossed Westland
and we took a left turn
so what's behind you.
>>Albano: So probably it
would be actually Mass Ave.
>>Teacher: Excellent.
>>It's like a spiral, it
goes all the way around.
>>Albano: Oh my god
>>Teacher: It's funny.
>>Albano: I'm trapped.
>>This is almost a
fully capable computer.
You can type in notes.
You can go online.
I'm pretty much signed on
to AOL Instant Messenger
as soon as I get home.
>>Computer: Message transmitted.
>>Albano: And let's see if he
actually says anything back.
There's this game called WarPath.
Dinosaurs from Jurassic Park
fighting in a fighting arena.
>>The sound in the game is
detailed enough so that I know
when I'm the one being hit.
The movement is like
only backward and forward
so there' no way I can stray off
a field or something like that.
>>Oh no you don't.
>>He is just about dead.
>>For more information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.